pis politique c'est le jeu de qui
soutient guy rabbo je vous donne à
nouveau me dit qui est soutien attention
nekfeu ce qu'il faut jean luc mélenchon
jean luc mélenchon bravo effectivement
fin il aurait été vu un meeting de jean
luc mélenchon voilà mais pour l'instant
ça a été démenti et de qu'on n'est pas
sûr attention brigitte bardot
bravo nicolas dupont aignan alors au
début elle soutenait zemmour et puis
comme il n'ya pas de la kul lui plaît le
pen aussi way comme il n'y a pas de très
cool et ça elle soutient dupont aignan
déjà elle se révolte contre le fait
qu'on parle pas beaucoup de lui dans les
médias oui pour qu'elle considère que
c'est celui qui défend le mieux la cause
des animaux ouais à l'est les leçons oui
mais bon on ne soutient pas forcément
des gens dont on consent à la base et
soutenait zemmour mais comme il l avait
pas du tout aimé son programme pour les
animaux mais du coup et s'est dirigé
vers 18 morts à hal médicaux a du pognon
mériteraient plus de temps de parole à
la télévision parce que son programme
politique pour la france est très bon
c'est aussi un grand défenseur des
animaux il est injuste qu'ils soient
autant envie dans les médias moi j'adore
brigitte bardot après j'adore pas tout
ce qu'elle dit mais elle a tout le monde
alors la grosse surprise alain delon
non mais la pièce maîtresse mélenchon
non maintenant mais pécresse écrit on se
rappelle que c'était un ami personnel de
jean marie le pen comme il est très
clair maintenant il est très clair il
est depuis quand les présidents alors
fait voler fédé dure depuis quand les
présidents en quarante piges donc vous
voyez pas fan de maquereaux difficile
être prise la république à 40 ans donc
il se tient mais craque je peux certes
pécresse était beaucoup plus vieux c'est
qu'on a encore un coup comme c'est un
argument vraiment nul appareil vous
savez quoi delon j'adore mais je suis
comme ces plans bardot boucher ouais
faut plutôt prendre c'est clair je
reprends mon il faut savoir
non mais c'est vrai tu vois philippe
chevallier roussel
à la fin alors il a une phrase génial et
dit je ne suis pas d'extrême droite je
suis souverainiste en tant que
souverainiste ne peut pas être européen
est d'ailleurs ma femme est sénégalaise
un ami juif nadine morano c'est
n'importe quoi j'ai très peur qu'il se
fasse à comment il s'appelait le petit
roux qui avait soutenu marine le pen ya
ça oui ma de la personne de la personne
impliquée de travailler derrière quand
même attention tu en fais un autre yvan
le bolloc'h facile bah si mélenchon bah
oui mêlant charge suivant le bolloc'h on
sait qu'il est très très très très à
gauche et ça alors un qui sort de nulle
part sur ma fiche sais pas si vous savez
giuseppe polimeno
non mais c'est quoi l'émission s'était
posée
c'est très intéressant qu'on sache pour
qu'ils sont fous de ce message à la
france et mon fils c'est son sac à main
voilà d'amour celle à lorient alors
c'est vrai qu'il a fait de la prison
mais il a payé et lui c'est eric zemmour
voilà il ya aussi le cabri tient pas qui
ça le papa de merrill lynch est passé en
chine fait quoi ils votent mélenchon
mais non mais toi tu m'aimes avait battu
vois tu vas prendre un truc françoise
hardy
joie chez vous aussi jouent à la maison
à
crouy lorraine parfois mais maintenant
j'ai longtemps
macron voyage avance a dit pas parce que
je veux qu'on fasse absolument on s'en
fait un petit dernier alors ça c'est ma
préférée alors attention elton john
elton john leighton vote en france ou
non mais la red john a dit je vous dis
je vous dit la phrase
présidente est ce que tu votes pour
quelqu'un il a répondu oui je réponds à
et vote for you
[Applaudissements]
créé à bordeaux qui parle anglais et toi
non mais belle réponse derrière dina
lohan la réponse derrière anne hidalgo
alors ça ça sent le gars qui est venu à
paris on lui a mis deux motards et un
bel hôtel mais évidemment c'était
semaine il a battu mathieu moi je trouve
ça normal que les personnages publics
ils disent pour qui ils vont voter parce
qu'on fait toujours un peu de politique
quand on passe à la télé on donne son
point de vue sur tu vas te kitwara
toujours moi ouais alors moi j'ai une
stratégie je vais voter au premier tour
jean luc mélenchon oui parce que j'ai
envie de voir un débat jean luc
mélenchon emmanuel macron d'accord ne
veut pas voter extraits d'opéra sont
alors je m'y attendais non mais au
second tour je voterai emmanuel macron
d'accord au nez ou pas ça sera mais
c'est ma stratégie à six y sont intenses
et rien que ça tombe en tout cas c'est
très courageux de dire pour qui votent
macrez maintenant les amis on va passer
à qu'est ce qui se passe au japon
alors au chauffeur de sa claque ou
non il ya des absences
vraiment courageux de la part du gauche
c'est bref je viens tu leur édito pour
qui tu vas tu leur ai dit moi non non
non d'accord d'accord quelqu'un veut lui
dire ici
dit quoi c'est tellement je suis
tellement dit ségolène royal à ce que
première non premier tour je vais voter
j'ai pas de choix macron a de bonnes
chances à ne pas voter bécret toujours
le choix très bien le jour le jour mais
vous savez que j'ai pas vous demander
c'est totalement personnel donc si vous
voulez dire vous dit sinon on passe à
autre chose